the future of ethical elephant is
sweetened by the illegal ivory trade
people are unable to organize collective
and effective conservation efforts a way
forward is to create a new social space
for cross-cultural understanding and
engagement I was almost killed by this
elephant in Kenya it was early morning
on the 4th of March 2015 I was brushing
my teeth by the bank of the river in the
Samburu National Reserve whether the
conservation group of elephants has
established a research camp lair
it was no long before I realized a Shree
metre told elephant was walking towards
me slowly and eloquently if you like a
dream as I look into his eyes but
suddenly the elephants start to flap in
his ears very fiercely and spending no
more than five meters away from me
I thought to myself oh no I'm done with
my life I turn and start blending and
yearing and as elephants that to charge
after me this was the most unforgettable
moment in my past eight years as a
professional conservationist fortunately
my life was saved when other colleagues
who were more familiar with the Hirst
rushed out of the camp and stopped the
elephant this experience always remind
me about extremely complexity of
wildlife conservation fundamentally
conservation is the bowel the way we
human beings collectively make decisions
as to sharing the planet Earth with
other white creatures just like building
the Tower of papel is not easy this is
not an easy task we do not speak a
single language we are different in
terms of our identity our perspective
and our priority our values how to
unravel such complex social interaction
and how to peel a broad coalition for
Wildlife Conservation given all these
differences has become the focus of my
pursuit in the past few years I still
remember how confused I were stand the
very beginning of my research the word
think China is the main destination for
illegal while a ivory Chinese pen tutor
very different story journalists and
conservationists believe economic growth
in China in the past three decades has
create a growing middle class who would
like to buy the ivory to show off less
social status but in China people
identified different ivory buyers and
they spent ivory trade in Chinese law a
big issue
ivory demand in China is very small and
what I saw is the Bremen games continued
I was exposed to all these different
stories I was very confused what was the
truth what was really going on there and
this motivates me to under text the
ivory trade as my Master's project a
year University on a surface the future
of ethical elephant is straightened by
the illegal ivory trade this is the
problem that most of us has already
observed but beneath the tip of iceberg
is the more fundamental problem people
are in disagreement and people are
unable to organize collective and
effective conservation efforts in
Western societies and in African
societies there are many misperceptions
prevalent about Chinese demand for ivory
the Chinese are equally ignorant about
what is going on in ethical many Chinese
do not accept the fact that elephant
poaching is serious in ethical many
things the ivory trade is just an excuse
that the Western society used to Bremen
er to criticize China in free of Chinese
presence in ethical the contentious
situation this kind of very conflict of
ivory trade reminds me of
story about bran man and elephant the
world outside and the picture in our
head can be very different
different people different group
different institution different states
from different angle usually see the
problem in a different way in order to
resolve the conflict and to solve the
problem it is very important that we
reconcile all these different
perspectives and a way forward I believe
is to create to innovate a new social
space for cross culture understanding
and engagement in 2014 I invite to
Kenyan conservationists on the trip to
China the three of us within just two
weeks we visit five cities of ivory
trading centers in the southern part of
China we did not represent any
organization we just went there as
individuals who really care about the
future of elephant we visit ivory market
we talk to the general public and we
interact with local NGOs our campaign
was covered by the military in every
city we want the interaction the first
to face interaction with my Kenyan
friends has held a Chinese audience to
gain a better understanding about
elephant poaching in Africa and what it
means to African people equally
important this experience also helped my
Kenyan friends to reflect on a previous
assumption about ivory market in China
in the past few years I have think more
and more organizations try to do the
same thing try to innovate new social
space to create the China Africa
conversation on conservation issues and
I believe this is the positive trend
that we should reinforce my research on
ivory trade has brought me to many press
around the world in ethical in Asia in
the u.s. in Europe in Australia and make
many people of different identities the
herders farmers conservationists
dangers ivory covers ivory buyers
poachers government officials the list
goes on and on we might be different in
a language with big in the culture we
practice in the society we live in but
what I found is almost all people I made
sure Sam go a common goal a common goal
for better life where they can retain
their dignity for themself and also
follows they care about
I believe this vision cannot be possible
without the healthy and flourishing
environment biodiversity that offers the
human society tones of benefit together
we can ensure the wonder and the jury of
Wildlife and witness can ask far into
the future thank you
you